Let's discuss the features and tools within Sequencer
and how they can impact your speed and efficiency when
using them.
Working our way numerically from one to five,
let's cover the Sequencer interface.
In section one, this is the toolbar,
which is a collection of commonly used tools
and settings within Sequencer.
We have the option to save the sequence,
browse to the sequence within the content browser,
create a new camera and set it as the current camera cut,
export the sequence to a movie or image sequence
via Movie Render Queue, open the Blueprint
Director for the sequence, execute various actions.
Now, note, many of these actions
are available in the interface or with hotkeys.
Change your interface layout and the information
that's displayed, and modify your playback options.
Now, the next three menu options
are some of the most commonly used
when working with Sequencer.
The first option gives the ability
to control default keying channels as well as
keyframe interpolation.
The next option is Auto Keyframe,
which will automatically create a key when parameters
have changed.
A Sequencer will only create a key if a previous key has
been created.
And lastly, we can restrict Sequencer's ability
to automatically create keys for properties
when they're modified within the sequence, the level,
or both.
The Viewport Selectability button
limits your ability to choose actors within the viewport.
When this button is active, you can only select objects
using the sequence.
You can disable snapping or enable it,
as well as change the snapping interval.
You could modify the frame rate of the sequence.
Finally, you can use the Curve Editor
for granular control over your keyframes.
Section 2 is the Outliner.
Actors and their properties that are part of the sequence
are displayed in this section.
Note, typically only some of the actor's keyable properties
will be shown here when the actor is added to the sequence.
You can add more keyable properties
using the Add button, the Plus button,
located on the Actors section, or by adding a keyframe
to the actor's properties from a detail panel.
Section 3 is our Timeline.
As the playhead advances, it will progress
through the various keyframes, triggers,
and events based on their position on the timeline.
Section 4 is the Selection tab, which
can be docked or the default flyout,
and contains many of the same properties displayed
when right-clicking an actor in the sequence.
Lastly, Section 5 contains our playback controls,
buttons to specify our in and out
points for the sequence or shot,
and our timeline zoom and view options.
Now, Recent Updates to Sequencer
allows you to filter tracks based
on your Outliner selections.
You can isolate only the selected tracks,
hide selected tracks, or display all.
After selecting a track or tracks,
the Sequencer Curves Editor can also
be used to manipulate keyframes and keyframe interpolations.
Now, across the top of the Sequencer Curve Editor window
are various features for displaying, manipulating,
scaling, and snapping your keyframes.
Additionally, you have the ability to set the keyframe
interpolations, as well as the in and out timings
for those keyframes.
The Add Level Sequence with Shots tool
is useful for automatically generating a master
sequence that includes a structured hierarchy
of nested sequences and associated sequences,
all within a highly organized folder structure.
While you'll most likely find that this tool doesn't work
perfectly for your established pipeline or desired folder
structure, I highly recommend you
play with it at least once to observe
the way Unreal creates the parent sequence,
nested child sequences, and the file and folder structures.